in part one we talked about the
mysterious count of saint germain he's
been called a prophet a sorcerer and an
immortal he's been spotted all over the
world for a thousand years some say and
even the count himself said that he was
cartophilus the legendary wandering jew
cursed by jesus with immortality the
count of saint germain advised kings
queens and emperors he was present at
every significant event in european
history and even was an important
contributor to america's struggle for
independence he spoke a dozen languages
fluently he played piano and violin like
a virtuoso he was an expert in art
science politics philosophy and history
he left an impression on everyone he met
but today we'll see if we can separate
the man from the myth
[Music]
in paranormal history there isn't a more
fascinating figure than the count of
saint germain and there are countless
stories about him spanning hundreds of
years but how many of these stories are
true every story about the count has him
fluent in a dozen languages and speaks
so well that he fools native speakers
this isn't accurate in historical
records the first we hear about saint
germain is his arrest in 1745 for being
a spy but the quote is never printed in
full when english authorities arrested
saint germain they said he spoke spanish
and portuguese like a native speaker he
was fluent in italian and spoke french
with a piedmont accent he spoke in
broken english enough to get by but
nowhere near fluent they assumed he was
from spain or portugal now it is true
that king louis was very taken with him
but king louis was not a deep thinker
the king's chief advisors considered
saint germain an arrogant imposter the
king's doctor said he was a quack the
count disappeared from france for
several years not because of some
spiritual mission but because the king's
chief minister ordered his arrest so he
fled the country when saint germain
turned casanova's coin into gold it
wasn't through a chemical process it was
sleight of hand something that irritated
casanova and casanova met him a few
times and said he was brilliant but
casanova also said the count was a con
man a spy or both when saint germain
fixed the king's diamond the diamond the
count brought back was of a different
cut and slightly larger st germain said
the diamond becoming larger was part of
the process he had an answer for
everything everything madame pompadour
the king's chief mistress was very
familiar with precious stones and she
looked through a box of the cow's gems
laughed and said they were fake she did
say they were very pretty but still fake
now yes voltaire did say that the count
of saint germain is the man who knows
everything and never dies i've seen this
quoted a million times but what's rarely
said is voltaire was being sarcastic he
was pretty much saying oh yeah that guy
now the story about the countess who
recognizes him from 50 years ago that
happened but the entire story isn't
often told the countess who was almost
90 was senile and everybody knew this
even saint germain said so when the
countess thought she met saint germain
years earlier she simply made a mistake
and set a legend in
[Music]
motion right those stories got started
because an english comedian named
millard gower started impersonating
saint germain as part of his act and
every time gower performed the stories
got crazier wait so this guy's a legend
because some comic was doing a bit yep
remember the count's last stop was the
castle of prince edward in germany
prince edward said the count of saint
germain was a small gray-haired elderly
man not a chatty 45 year old when saint
germain died in 1784 allegedly allegedly
his death was witnessed and his
belongings were meticulously documented
there were no diamonds no elixirs and
the only money to his name was about 80
reich dollars oh how many millions is
that uh it's about 100 bucks oh when
theosophos madame levotsky said she had
saint germain's secret documents she
actually had a copy of a memoir written
a few years earlier and the memoir
didn't contain mystical knowledge just
biographical information and stories
about a charming man who is good at
talking people's ears off eventually
blavatsky was exposed as a fraud by a
whistleblower in her movement but plenty
of occultists were fans of the count
look maybe guy ballard really did meet
saint germain on mount shasta i don't
know i wasn't there but i do know that
ballard plagiarized a lot of his
material from science fiction books and
was found guilty of fraud so you be the
judge so do we know who he really was
maybe
the count of saint germain is said to be
from everywhere some say he was a high
priest from atlantis or he was a prophet
from the middle east he's said to be
merlin the wizard plato saint alban
christopher columbus one of the last
templar knights people claim that roger
bacon was the count then they claimed
francis bacon was the count what about
kevin bacon i wouldn't be surprised
kevin bacon's been around a long time
now on his deathbed the count of saint
germain confessed that he was the son of
francis ricosi ii prince of transylvania
and he was 88 years old to avoid being a
political target he was sent to italy to
study with the last of the medicis now
this would explain his wealth his
excellent education and why he spoke so
many languages but still if this story
were true he would have been almost 70
years old when he was at versailles not
45 and his father prince francis would
have been 15 years old when the count
was born
not impossible not likely another theory
is that saint germain was an alsatian
jew named simon wolfe born around 1700
and he hid his identity to avoid
religious persecution others say he was
a spanish jesuit named amar his true
title was the marquis de betmar from
portugal this explains why his spanish
and portuguese sounded so perfect none
other than pt barnum took an interest in
the count and did his own research and
nobody knows a good scammer better than
barnum using barnum's research and their
research from other historians i think
the best theory is that saint germain
was the son of an italian princess the
princess had an illicit affair with an
italian tax collector when the count was
a child he was separated from his mother
he was given a world-class education a
lump sum of money and instructions to
hide his true identity this theory
suggests he was born around 1690 in a
region of italy called san germano what
does sanjamata mean in english st
germain yeah i should have put that
together myself san germano is on the
northern border of italy and switzerland
directly to the west is france this
region is called piedmont that so-called
unidentifiable accent he spoke with
native speakers identified his accent as
distinctly piedmont something that's
been documented and if he had been born
in this area he would have grown up
speaking french italian and german
interchangeably the jump to speaking
spanish and portuguese from there isn't
difficult and if you're fluent in french
and german english would come pretty
easily too but still these are just
theories nobody except the count himself
knew his true origin he enjoyed the
mystery that surrounded him so he fed
into his own myth wherever he could he
was a legend yes but a legendary con man
he never stole from anyone but he was
perfectly happy to live rent-free in
castles palaces and lavish apartments
all over europe the count was a
brilliant man who used his charm and
intellect to befriend wealthy
influential people to support his
lifestyle eventually his charm and money
ran out and he died virtually penniless
even in the face of all this evidence
many people still believe he is an
immortal who walks the earth to this day
i don't but the legend of the count of
saint germain is such a good one i want
to be wrong but i can tell you this for
certain if i'm ever sitting on a quiet
mountain and approached by a mysterious
man who claims to be the count of saint
germain i'll be skeptical but still i'm
going to listen to what that man has to
say because
you never know
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything do us a favor and like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps out a small channel until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you
are appreciated
[Music]
you